hey guys I'm Ryan right hello there I'm
Veronica so today we're gonna be
checking out an honest game trailer for
Mortal Kombat X I figured why not she
played it for the first time I did she
was great it was it was pretty fun she
lost both times to two different people
the following trailer is rated H for
honest because Street Fighter 5 is still
a year away and Smash Bros Wii U doesn't
really count fighting game fans will
have to tie themselves over with Mortal
Kombat X privacy's of your keyboard
because Mortal Kombat is back even
though it's kind of in back for a while
but now it's even backer in the best
Mortal Kombat experience since you beat
your older brother the MK 2 machine is
called take that Kraig prepare for a
deep well balanced action-packed
fighting game but who cares we know why
you really hear you say geeks Gore play
the next generation of interactive snuff
films with fatalities the treat blood
like Gatorade brutalities where you
punch someone so hard and they're dead
their eyes pop out yeah killer old lady
projectile and x-ray equals that somehow
don't result in integer
ouch walk it off how about the Gordo
dive into an extensive story mode where
the Teen Titans of Earth realm search
were a magical necklace that will have
you constantly pausing to look up their
route list in this three hour cutscene
interrupted by the occasional QuickTime
event aggressively stupid line of
dialogue you got caged
and a tea party master's plans but
Sektor had realized his father's vision
the Lin Kuei had been fully cyber eyes
and pledging sceptre and his followers
reform the Lin Kuei and restore our
honor
select your combatant from the next
generation of Fighters newcomers who
look like they were designed by an
angsty middle schooler and your old
favorites who are now just really
old-looking
you lost colby locks okay grandpa head
online for the Ultimate Mortal Kombat
challenge of fighting scorpion over and
over and over again and do battle
against lag so bad you might as well be
drawing the match by hand
hahahahahahaha but in all worth it when
every victory earned you sweet sweet
faction experience which you can use to
it uh which you can use to yeah I don't
know they're about as arbitrary as
Hogwarts boys 472 points Slytherin house
so enjoy the latest from the franchise
that started as a bloody gimmick but
grew into a really solid fighting game
with the bloody gimmick and if that core
game isn't enough drown in an avalanche
of extra content like the crit a store
menu with jump scares for some reason Oh
test your luck the mote you play when
you're drunk test your might the finger
bag simulator oh no my head
what the hell and if you're a rich idiot
who sucks at the game and why spend
$5.00 for 30 easy fatality tokens which
I mean seriously that's worse than a
horse armor you were doing so well and
food shame on you and shame on your
giant greedy eyebrows ready
starring nepotism not the piece her
maker
Kid Rock but wrong jack see getting too
old for this John Cage mange huh place
it pin this on the donkey fan club
a popular dog game Hawkeye or just
regular guy Patrick my teeth are up here
[ __ ] my PK Thunder Chris Bosh
get over here hey les ice bucket
challenge you whip it good and sugar key
the Mortal Kombat times did you know if
you beat the game with sub-zero he
becomes Khaleesi they accepted their Lin
Kuei masters and their training as
combat mounts
with a force of Dragon Riders the Lin
Kuei ferocity became legend Oh spoiler
alert be sure to subscribe for more
honest game trailers weirdly it caused
me to respect the game a little bit more
I know they're like making fun of it but
you know to see the evolution of the
game of how it started off into where it
is now and how many different choices
you get for a fighting game I don't know
it just like really shows you like how
different this game is like sure the
violence is kind of gimmick but you know
like no other fighting game is willing
to go all out like that and it kind of
kind of respect that they're willing to
go so far with it you always say that
you said that for that one
mass-murdering game hatred yeah yeah mad
respect for hatred [ __ ] love that
idea
it's murdering innocent don't you ever
bring that game into our apartment I'm
going to buy it the day it comes out and
it's going to be the first game I play
on this channel I will not allow it's
gonna be my first let's play you can
wait outside anyway guys thanks for
informing us that was out if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects Veronica v6 dose has a
channel too there's a lot of acoustic
covers check those out it's awesome and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter
and normally I do a joke here about
product placement because if I get
enough followers I can get product
placement potentially but [ __ ] the sex
chug let's do a shout-out instead
Taylor Campbell just a shout-out to you
guys are real rejects you guys are
awesome hilarious thanks Taylor
Campbell you know Taylor can be a boy or
a girl name yes that's true and Taylor
Campbell um let's let's identify your
gender it is a boy he's a white boy
Taylor kind of looks like uhm yeah I get
a cannibal vibe from him uh-huh you
don't get a cannibal vibe uh-huh that's
like that is everything if someone said
here's a picture of a cannibal and then
they showed you a picture taylor
campbell wouldn't you be like oh wow
that's so that's what cannibal looks
like that sort of what i imagined taylor
you don't look like a cannibal see right
here he looks like a nice cannibal
anyway taylor there's your shout out my
mail taylor friend